so let's see if we can find the
maclaurie's
the maclaurin series representation of f
of x where f of x is equal to x to the
third times cosine of x squared i
encourage you to pause the video and now
try to do and remember the core in
series is just the taylor series
centered at zero and let's say our goal
here is the first five
non-zero terms of the maclaurin series
representation or maclaurin series
approximation of this
so i'm assuming you had paused the video
and you had attempted to do this and
there's a good chance that you might
have gotten quite frustrated when you
did this because in order to find a
taylor series maclaurin series we need
to find the derivatives of this function
and as soon as you start to do that it
starts to get painful f prime of x
is going to be let's see product rule so
it's three x squared times cosine of x
squared plus x to the third
times the derivative of this thing which
is going to be 2x
times negative sine of x negative sine
of x squared so just that was pretty
painful but it's going to get more and
more painful as we take the second and
third and fourth derivatives we might
have to take more because some of these
terms might end up being zeros because
we want the first five non-zero terms so
the second derivative this is going to
be
painful
this is going to be painful and then the
third and fourth derivatives are going
to be even more painful
so what do we do here you could just do
this and just evaluate immediate zero
and then use those two for our
coefficients but you're probably
guessing correctly that there's an
easier way to do this
and i will give you a hint
we know what the pot what we know what
the the maclaurin series for cosine of x
is we've done that in a previous video
if you if you want to see that again
there's another video look up cosine
taylor series at zero on khan academy
and you'll find that but we already know
from that and this is one of the most
famous
maclaurin series we know this let's just
say g of x let's say g of x
is equal to cosine of x
well we know how this what this is like
the the maclaurin series approximation
of that is going to be
1 minus
x squared over 2 factorial plus
x to the fourth over four factorial
minus x to the sixth over six factorial
plus and i could keep going on and on
and on you kind of see where this is
going plus x to the eighth
over eight factorial and it just keeps
going minus plus on and on and on and on
but we wanted first eight five terms so
this is a star and i know we wanted the
first five terms of this thing but bear
with me we'll see how this thing right
over here is going to be useful
so now that i've given you a little bit
of reminder on the maclaurin series
representation of cosine of x
my hint to you is can we use this
to find the maclaurin series
representation of this right up here and
remember all this is this is x to the
third times and i'm just rereading it
for you this is x to the third times
g
of x squared so that's a a sizable hint
i encourage you to pause the video again
and see if you can work through this
so let me rewrite i'm assuming you had a
go at it so let me rewrite what i just
wrote so i just i just told you
that g of x
so or f of x
f of x
if i want to write it as if i wanted to
write it as i guess you could say as a
as a function or if i want to construct
it using g of x
i could rewrite it as x to the third
time instead of cosine of x squared
that's the same thing as g of x squared
so x to the third
times g
g of x squared
g
of
x squared
this g of x is just cosine g of x
squared is going to be cosine of x
squared and you're going to multiply
that times x to the third
well
can't we just apply this insight to the
approximation and you might be asking
that question and my answer to you is
yes you absolutely can and notice when
you substitute your x's for x squared
you'll just get another polynomial and
if you multiply that by x to the third
you're just going to get another
polynomial and that actually will be
the maclaurin series representation of
what we started off with we actually
will get the maclaurin series
representation of this thing right over
here so we could say that f of x
is approximately equal to
x to the third times
x to the third times let me give myself
some space right over here
so g of x squared so over here this is
approximation for g of x and if we kept
going on and on forever it would be a
representation of g of x so every place
where we see an x let's replace it with
an x squared so this is going to be one
minus so x squared squared is x to the
fourth
x to the fourth over two factorial which
is really just two but i like to put the
factorial there because you see the
pattern
plus
if our x is now x squared x squared to
the fourth power is x to the eighth
x to the eighth power
four over four factorial
minus
x squared to the sixth power is x to the
twelfth
over six factorial
and then plus
x squared to the eighth is x to the
sixteenth power over eight factorial
and of course we can keep going on and
on and on minus plus but we just care
about the first five terms non-zero
terms and we're saying this is an
approximation anyway
and so we can say that this is going to
be approximately equal to we distribute
the x to the third and i'm gonna do it
in magenta just for fun
so distribute the x to the third we get
x to the third
minus
x to the seventh
over two factorial
plus x to the 11th
over 4 factorial minus
x to the 15th
over 6 factorial
plus
x to the 19th
over eight factorial so that's the first
five nine zero terms and we are done and
when you actually see what we got you
realize it would have taken you forever
to do this by i guess you could say by
brute force because you would have had
to find the 19th derivative of all of
this madness but when you realize that
hey gee
if i can just re-express this function
as essentially a a a x to a power times
something that i know the maclaurin
series of especially well if you view it
this way if i can write
if i can rewrite
let me see it in a less confusing way
if i can rewrite my function
so it is equal to some
actually i can even throw a coefficient
here if it's equal to some ax to the n
power
times some function let me just send a
new color times dude purple
times
g
of
b
x to some other power
where i can
fairly easily without too much
computation maybe i already even know
if i know the maclaurin series
representation of g of x if i know what
g of x is going to be then i can do
exactly what i did just in this video i
find the maclaurin series representation
for g every place where i saw an x i
replace it with what i have over here
the bx to the m power where m is some
some exponent that will give me another
polynomial another power series and then
i multiply it times ax to the n and
that's going to once again give me
another power series and that will be
the power series for my original
function very exciting